>> Rachel: FOX NEWS ALERT.
TONIGHT WE HAVE OBTAINED LEAKED
DOCUMENTS COURTESY OF CHRIS RUFO
REPORTEDLY FROM INSIDE GOOGLE
EXPOSING THE FIRST RACIAL
BRAINWASHING GOING ON INSIDE OF
ONE OF AMERICA'S LARGEST AND
MOST POWERFUL TECH COMPANIES.
ONE GRAPHIC ALLEGEDLY CREATED BY
GOOGLE'S DEFENDANT AND INCLUSION
LEAD CLAIMS THAT EXPRESSIONS OF,
QUOTE:  SOCIALLY ACCEPTABLE
WHITE SUPREMACY INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE CELEBRATING COLUMBUS DAY,
THE DENIAL OF WHITE PRIVILEGE
AND THE PHRASE MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN.
WHILE ANOTHER GRAPHIC SHOWS
CONSERVATIVE COMMENTATOR BEN
SHAPIRO AND FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP ARE ONLY A FEW
STEPS AWAY FROM, QUOTE MASS
MURDERERS ON THE WHITE SUPREMACY
PYRAMID.
IT IS A DISTURBING DISCOVERY
MADE ALL THE MORE TERRIFYING
WHEN YOU REMEMBER THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
NEARLY EVERYTHING YOU SEE
ONLINE.
MANHATTAN INSTITUTE SENIOR
FELLOW CHRIS RUFO IS HERE NOW
WITH MORE ON THIS.
CHRIS, THIS IS REALLY
DISTURBING.
HARD TO BELIEVE AND IF I LOOK AT
THE LIST, LIKE HALF OF AMERICA
THEN IS A WHITE SUPREMACIST AND
I WONDER, CHRIS, IS THAT THE
POINT, THAT YOU CAN CRUSH YOUR
POLITICAL IDEOLOGICAL ENEMIES
AND STILL CLAIM THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THEY
ARE RACIST?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
FOR YEARS NOW COMPANIES IN
SILICON VALLEY INCLUDING GOOGLE
ARE IDEOLOGICAL ECHO CHAMBERS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED.
I HAVE DOCUMENTS NOW FROM A
THIRD OF THE FOR COUNTRY 100
COMPANIES PROMOTING SIMILARLY
THEMED ANTI-RACISM PROGRAMS.
AND THIS AN IN THE CONFINES OF
SILICON VALLEY IS CONSIDERED NOT
ONLY UNUSUAL IT'S CONSIDERED
VIRTUOUS.
>> THEY SLANDER AND DEGRADE HALF
THE COUNTRY AND MAKE THIS ABSURD
ASSERTION THAT SOMEONE LIKE BEN
SHAPIRO, WHO IS A PERSON OF
CONVICTION, A PERSON OF
CHARACTER, IS SOMEHOW ON THE
ROAD TO GENOCIDE.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
THEY SHOULD RETRACT AND
ELIMINATE THIS PROGRAM
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Rachel: GOOGLE CONTROLS
VIRTUALLY ALL INFORMATION FLOW
IN OUR COUNTRY.
I MEAN, IT'S REALLY FRIGHTENING
HOW MUCH POWER THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE.
AND SO I'M NOT JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT FREE SPEECH.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT ELECTIONS.
I MEAN, THEY HAVE CONTROL OF
INFORMATION AND WHAT CANDIDATES
SAY OR DON'T GET TO SAY ON THESE
PLATFORMS.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, THE FACT IS
THAT GOOGLE CONTROLS THE
INFORMATION FLOW OF THE UNITED
STATES.
EVERYTHING FROM WHAT YOU SEARCH
IN YOUR BROWSER TO WHETHER A YOU
SEE ON YOUTUBE, TO ALL OF THE
IMAGE AND WORLD'S LIBRARY.
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARILY POWERFUL
TOOL THAT COULD DO A LOT OF
GOOD.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE CULTURE
INSIDE COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE
MATTERS AND WHEN IT'S HIJACKED
BY RACIAL IDEALOGUES IT CAN DO
TREMENDOUS DAMAGE, NOT ONLY TO
GOOGLE'S USERS AND CONSUMERS BUT
ACTUALLY TO AMERICAN SOCIETY, WE
HAVE TO KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THESE COMPANIES, INSIDE THESE
MONOPOLIES, AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S -- WHAT IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF A COMPANY LIKE
GOOGLE, ALIENS WITH THE INTEREST
OF THIS COUNTRY, THE UNITED
STATES, AND WHEN WE SEE THESE
DOCUMENTS, WHEN IT'S EXPOSED, IT
SHOULD DRAW SERIOUS CONCERNS NOT
ONLY FROM THE PEOPLE BUT FROM
POLICYMAKERS IN D.C.
>> Rachel: WHAT ABOUT FROM ALL
OF US?
I AGREE WITH YOU 100 PERCENT.
OUR GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT OUR CONGRESS.
BUT, IN ADDITION, WHAT CAN WE
PERSONALLY DO?
I KNOW MY HUSBAND IS REALLY BIG
ON SAYING I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THESE PEOPLE THAT WANT
CRUSH CONSERVATIVES, HE DOESN'T
USE GOOGLE.
HE MAKES A POINT OF ALWAYS GOING
TO DUCK DUCK GO OR USES RUMBLE.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR
CONSERVATIVES TO MAKE THOSE, YOU
KNOW, VERY DELIBERATE DECISIONS
TO CHANGE WHERE THEY ARE
GETTING -- WHAT PLATFORMS
THEY'RE USING, HOW THEY ARE
GETTING THEIR INFORMATION AND
THEN HOPEFULLY ALSO CREATE MORE
PLATFORMS AND TECHNOLOGY THAT
ISN'T GOING TO TO, YOU KNOW,
CRUSH CONSERVATIVES?
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BUT I
THINK ULTIMATELY IT WILL PROVE
TO BE INSUFFICIENT.
THE RELATES IS THAT THERE ARE
MOP MONOPOLY CONDITIONS ACROSS
MANY DIFFERENT VERTICALS IN THE
TECH WORLD.
AND THIS IS REALLY A PUBLIC
POLICY PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU HAVE MONOPOLY
CONDITIONS, EVEN IF YOU ARE A
STRINGENT LIBERTARIAN, IT
JUSTIFIES SOME INTERVENTION,
SOME REGULATION.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE TECH
COMPANIES SHOULD BE REGULATED AS
COMMON CARRIERS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN'T DENY SOMEONE THE PHONE
SERVICE FROM AT&T BECAUSE OF
THEIR POLITICAL VIEWS IT SHOULD
BE THE SAME SORE SOMETHING LIKE
GOOGLE.
WHAT WE SEE INSIDE THESE
COMPANIES IS THAT INCREASINGLY,
THE IDEOLOGY OF GOOGLE EMPLOYEES
IS ACTIVELY HOSTAGE TO THE
UNITED STATES AND OTHER
DOCUMENTS THEY SAY AND OTHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS THEY SAY THAT
THE UNITED STATES IS A SYSTEM OF
WHITE SUPREMACY AND THAT
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY IS,
QUOTE:  RAISED TO BE RACIST.
THIS IS A DEEPLY FALSE AND
DAMAGING KIND OF THINKING.
IT SHOULD HAVE NOWHERE IN
AMERICA'S BIGGEST AND MOST
POWERFUL COMPANIES.
>> Rachel: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
IT NEEDS TO BE HANDLED BY
CONGRESS.
YOU ARE SO RIGHT.
CHRIS, THANK YOU FOR BREAKING
THAT WITH US TONIGHT.